Once upon a time people wrote this way.
You couldn't even buy a vowel.
Someone had to invent them.
It might've had been something like this,
Greece, Greece, Greece.
Before there was a Parthenon,
a stern old man in a trademark,
sporty Toga, seems a bit on edge.
As he glares at the pirates sheet
clutched in his hand. You see,
you try to shrug off his outburst,
but he can't let this go. My friend,
my friend, he recounts how 500
years before he was even born,
when the walls of Troy still stood, the
Greeks had a writing system of their own.
It was one of those more elaborate
syllabary plus Logograph types.
But that script had come and it had gone.
The new Greeks were people on the rise,
but I know literate people on the rise
of people looking for something new,
something great, and this
alphabet thing seems great almost.
He calls over his close friends.
The Phoenician consonants are useful,
he can seeds, but why these
extra characters for huffing,
coughing and clearing your throat.
These are barbarian sounds.
Greeks have no need for them.
And what about the voicing
noises? Like Ah, Ooh,
how to write them. Huh? So
much extra yet so much missing.
What a mess you tried to explain,
but they laugh it off
here. I fixed for you. He says, see,
he was going to ditch
the barbarian letters,
but he had second thoughts
and it struck him.
Why not use these on Greek sounds
for vowels. The one you call a left,
ignore the throaty catch at the
beginning. It's, ah, take that. Hey,
but ditch the huh.
And we're left with a vowel Lee.
A loosen up that tight wa
in. Wow. And it's the vow.
Ooh,
this isn't just a small correction.
This is a powerful major moments
in the history of writing.
He's fundamentally shifted the
way the alphabet functions.
It used to be just the continent
suggesting the pronunciation of a word.
Once you recognize the word,
the job's done.
But Greek spelling isn't merely
about writing recognizable words.
It's about matching letters to sounds.
A new principal has just emerged,
perhaps even a new goal.
One sound, one character.
You suspect that he's not even aware of
the impact of his discovery as he tells
you to drop everything and come enjoy
some dinner and dancing. Hippy silly.
The party goes on and on so long that
your new friends don't even see what's
happening beyond the walls of their city.
State, this continent, bowel, alphabet,
this pronunciation,
writing, it's spreading,
inspiring new alphabets to the east
with flavors like Armenian in Cyrillic,
popping up out west in Italy.
The skins,
the Etruscans borrow it and
they pass it on to the Romans.
The Romans burst down in,
splatter it among the Celts in Germanic
peoples and eventually the world such as
visual rainbow of variations,
and yet they'll all stick with the basic
principle of writing a character for
each sound, consonants
and vowels. Finally,
you see your writing system in this story,
your alphabet,
all because a handful of submit, simple.
It's got mistaken for Greek vowels,
but before you get over confident,
know that the history of
writing doesn't stop here.
This isn't the be all and end all,
not even close.